all right alexis yes alexis uh where did
you grow up where are you from
originally so i live in dallas texas now
but i grew up in kentucky
born in texas moved to kentucky for a
little bit of my childhood and then we
ended up moving back to texas so you're
you're a dallas girl now i am
and how was your childhood
now that i'm getting a little bit older
i realized that there was so much trauma
in my childhood that kind of
developed
who i am today like my personality my
characteristics why i do some of the
things that i do
looking back it was filled full of a lot
of trauma um my sister was murdered on
her 24th birthday and that did a number
of things to my mom
that
kind of crafted our relationship or
like the dependency that i had on
another human being growing up
um she resulted to
coping with drugs
or
um
just things that weren't like generally
good for her she kind of just
gave up for a while
things are a little bit better now but
um
i have definitely used those experiences
to learn and grow
what kind of kid were you in high school
high school was very different for me i
think about it all the time how i wish i
had this confidence and this
intelligence about myself that i had in
high school i was very very very anxious
i tried to get into sports a little bit
later into high school and did pretty
well but i didn't have like that support
to really blossom into something like
that i um
had tons of friends but i feel like i
got all the wrong attention um because
my mom was kind of lacking in that
department i was seeking attention and
all the wrong things so i would smoke i
would party for the earlier years of
high school and that kind of got me
like a bad reputation that i had to grow
out of as i got older
but um overall there are so many things
that i wish i could do differently in
high school
and you're after after high school you
entered college
so no i actually um after high school i
didn't really know what i was gonna do i
didn't go to college until two years
later i took a year
off i moved to italy i lived in italy
for a couple of months and then i moved
back and i read this book that kind of
like jump-started me to
apply for college and i graduate in may
i've had a 4.0 this whole time it's very
important to me that i kind of make up
for my mistakes in high school just in
college it's great thank you
and do you have
goals of doing something with your life
after school
i can never imagine myself being
poor
because i grew up poor there were times
that we didn't have electricity or my
phone service would be shut off or
we would have all these weird random
people staying with us to try to like
make ends meet um
so
i'm not necessarily sure what it's going
to be but i know that the end goal is
i'm going to have financial freedom in
my life
and you're doing something now that that
is
yes helping you with your financial so
situation ever since i moved to dallas
because i had originally grown up in
amarillo poor with a mom who was
addicted to drugs and going through that
lifestyle um i had picked up and moved
to dallas just on a whim one day i knew
that that wasn't what i wanted my life
to be and i was bartending at first and
i had lived with this girl in a
rent-a-room situation who told me she
was also bartending she had great hours
she always had money
um
and she never could give me like a
direct on what her schedule was so i
asked her to get me a job where she
worked and it turns out that she was um
a dancer
so it was something that i was really
really apprehensive to at first i was
like no way that could never be me i had
the same stigmas in my mind that most
other people do whenever i tell them
what i do
and um
but i i knew that money was like the
end-all be-all for me so
i gave it a shot and i've never
i mean i now i'm the most successful one
out of all of my family and not all of
them know that i dance
but um they all know that i've done
really really well for myself since
moving
and that's a big big reason why i still
do what i do despite
like how awful and toxic the industry is
and can be
have you had bad experiences like that
that would make you say that all the
time so the first thing that
really
keeps me from telling someone what i do
is because their first thought is like
oh
there's a price there's a price for you
or you let all these people touch you or
you're a [ __ ] or you're on drugs which
is the case a lot of times but it's hard
for me to kind of convince someone i
almost feel like i shouldn't have to
convince someone that i'm not
doing those things at the club
there have been times every single night
i go everyone asks me how much to take
you here like can i take you back home
or can we just do it here or how much
how much how much and it just gets so
discouraging
because there are other women that are
doing this in the club at the club or
they are going home with you
prostitution and sex trafficking is a
very big thing
at strip clubs and i don't understand
why someone would do that at the club
where it's illegal in texas like if
you're gonna do it just go to like new
york or somewhere where it's legal and
just go be the best at it go make more
money go be legal go be clean
but i mean everyone's got different
circumstances and it definitely does
happen
and it's hard to kind of like
obviously there are ways to swindle your
way out of it like
no that's not me or i just met you and
you i have to keep the dream alive but
like i'd never have done anything like
that at the club and i never will
there's also tons and tons of pimps so
and i mean that and not in like the
stereotypical like someone's backhanding
you give me all your money type of way
the managers if they know that you're
doing extras or you're selling yourself
which they are totally okay with um
they'll try to make a profit off of you
like you're just a number to them
someone wants
everyone's trying to make money off yeah
if someone wants it they're gonna come
grab you take you to this man and break
them off a piece
so by day you're a college student i am
and by night you're a stripper i am it's
kind of a busy life i live how is that
contrast of of lifestyles play out with
you
it's very very difficult especially
being 22 trying to figure out who i am
because it's like i have all these goals
and ambitions and like the money's
really good my sleep schedule's crazy on
saturday nights i get off work at 6 00
am
but um
[Music]
it's
fine like it's manageable obviously i
get to pick my own schedule which is a
big big factor in this
um so i'm able to do all of my
schoolwork during the day i'm able to
take the time off if i need have like a
really
big exam coming up to study and i won't
ever have to worry about if my lights
are going to get shut off while i'm
doing it right
you're making good money and you're you
got a 4.0 yes
that's a hell of a combination thank you
do you have a boyfriend
i don't and dating has has been very
weird for me throughout this situation
because
there is a lot of trauma in the strip
club especially for me like i'm
kind of more like emotionally
intelligent
so
at this particular time in my life i
don't like to be touched or i get a lot
of like
affirmation at the club that i don't
necessarily want so it's like that thing
like am i really this pretty are you
looking at me half naked
like what's going on
um
but it's it's hard for me i think to
find someone that i meet and i'm
attracted to and we connect
and for them to be okay with what i do
but obviously
i'm doing it for the money and the
freedom
so i'm gonna pick that over
a man in a day
and i don't plan on doing this forever
one day i'll find somebody that
that i can like have a life with but
it's just it's kind of a really
complicated situation at this time in my
life is it gonna be hard for you to walk
away from the fast money
i
think so there have been times that i
have left um
the previous club that i had worked out
was actually like the the most
well known for extras
and so it was just re it beat me down
every day to go in there three four days
a week and just see it happening right
next to me so i left for a bit and
extras are
like sexual favors prostitution anything
of the sort
um i left for a bit i went back to
bartending and it just wasn't
that's whenever i started to stress
about money i had blown through my
savings i obviously wasn't making enough
money and i had gotten myself accustomed
to this lifestyle
that
not necessarily i couldn't afford but i
couldn't afford like very comfortably
but in the end whenever i do decide to
leave i always know that there's going
to be something bigger and better i'm
going to make comparable money and i'm
going to do whatever i can while i'm in
this industry to get out and live
in the same comfort financially
what makes you different than maybe your
classmates who just could never
imagine doing something like this oh my
gosh well number one i've never done
anything that's so character building in
my life to go and do this and be you
know
undressed next to tons of other
beautiful women
that
maybe have more confidence or maybe it's
just a facade has it built your
confidence
it takes a tremendous amount of
confidence to walk out there in a room
full of strangers naked
are you is it a nude club or tacos i in
texas uh full moon is optional and i
have never done full nude i do topless
um has it built my confidence it has and
it hasn't like it has because
like i said i go and i get all this
attention and people are paying me
to sit down and talk to them they want
to get to know me they're telling me
constantly you're so pretty you're so
pretty but obviously you know there's a
lot of things that are involved in that
i think that overall i'm pretty
confident in that i am
[Music]
i'm i'm a good person and i'll never
step down from my values and morals um
so i guess in a way yes like i know that
if i can go and do this
then really
what else could scare me
but it's something that um
not everybody's cut out for yeah i know
that all of like social media and music
and pop culture right now especially
with like the new artists that are
number one number two
they're advocating this lifestyle of
like you just go in you make money and
you leave like it's so much fun you're
getting drunk like it's you just live a
rich lifestyle like you're winning but
it's really not like that like there are
tons of times that i've had girls in the
back crying because
these men will
really just disrespect the [ __ ] out of
you
and it's i mean it's it's tough there's
tons of competition there are girls who
are way more aggressive than you are and
they're
they'll do anything to get that money
versus you getting that money
are you just able to compartmentalize
this
as something you're just doing for money
yeah absolutely and i think it's my
closest friends in my life know what i
do and my mom knows what i do and i they
they obviously know who i am as a person
we grew up together but
as far as like
meeting
other people i don't like to tell them
what i do so i kind of keep it as like
this other part of my life and no one
can really imagine me doing it which is
kind of crazy like i talked to my friend
the other day and i was like you know i
just go and give like lap dances for
seven hours so i just come home with all
this money like could you imagine me in
that situation and they say no all the
time would you recommend like a girl
watching this
who needs money for school or for
whatever
doing this kind of kind of work you have
to
you have to be concrete and solid
in your way of life like if you have any
doubt or any suspicion
whatsoever that you're gonna go and
you're gonna need assistance to do this
like i.e
drugs alcohol because you're allowed to
drink at the club i've seen girls throw
up in the bathroom tons of times
if you think that that's going to be any
sort of an issue then don't i think
it'll wreck you because
because you're going and you're doing
these things and you're coming home with
lots of cash which you obviously haven't
been exposed to before
and it's it's something that
can easily easily destroy you or or make
you lost especially at such like a young
age in your life
what is what does it tell you about men
talking about men what has it taught you
about men
that men really do wholeheartedly
objectify you
like and i never
realized to what extent that they do but
since i've been a dancer now like
whenever i go out like grocery shopping
or getting gas i'm more
like apt to notice these men just
looking me up and down and it's i read a
study once that like men
they um it activated the same brain
waves as
literally an object like a naked woman's
body
and i mean men will say and do
anything
for sex
it's crazy a lot of people these guys
probably have girlfriends or married do
you think all the time there are tons of
men that come in that are married and
like it's no big deal um my perspective
on it is like you
are out drinking the bars are closed you
don't want to stop partying so you go to
the club and it's just like
in good fun
but then there are the men that come in
obviously like
i'm just gonna get what i need from this
place and then head out almost like a
brothel
but um
a lot of the girls make money with these
extras right oh of course i've watched
girls walk out with
ten thousand dollars i've watched a girl
cash in five grand and chips and i'm
like
i don't know personally like i respect
every woman that does this i know it's
hard i know everyone's going through
their own things
but personally i couldn't imagine the
drive home
like after doing that all day
i just don't know how i'd be able to
like
cope with something like that
what's what's been the most memorable
night of yours doing this
money-wise or like experience-wise
either way whatever
money-wise
uh there was a time that i made
close to three grand in one night i had
just got really lucky and a big part of
this is you just have to meet the right
person say the right things to kind of
like snake your way through the
conversation
um
experience wise
i can't honestly say that i've ever had
like a great time at work there are tons
of times that i
am getting ready for work and i'm like i
really don't want to go tonight
um just because these guys are
doing what they're doing dude right tend
to not respect them like emotionally and
physically
just blatant disrespect but also i don't
think a lot of people talk about the
physical aspect of this like i'm wearing
six inch platform heels and i'm dancing
and
it's it's like a workout and i'm
sweating the whole time and it's it's
definitely hard like on my body
sometimes i wake up in the morning and
i'm like
i feel like i just got hit by a bus
yeah it's very physical work right for
sure
what did your mom say about it when she
found out
i called my mom the second that my
roommate had told me about what she did
and i actually
didn't ever show up for an interview for
about two weeks i was so nervous and i
just thought there was no way that i
could do that
so once i showed up for my interview i
was 40 pounds heavier i went for night
shift and i dressed in business casual
clothes resume in my hand you don't have
to do that they take your shirt off of
you or not like physically but like take
your shirt off turn around do you have
tattoos and they basically give you yes
or no because i was 40 pounds heavier i
got a no they said you can work a day
shift so
if you think dancing is character
building dancing during the day shift is
character building
um
but your mom my mom i called her that
night after i had gotten the notes that
they said i could work day shift and i
was like hey i think i want to be a
stripper her first reaction was like
don't do that like there's drugs
involved this is an awful lifestyle
please don't get involved and then the
next day she called me and she was like
okay like i think that you can do this
and she's been there she knows about it
the whole time i've done it i've done it
for about a year and a half now whenever
she visited me in dallas she actually
dropped me off at the club that i was
working at
so she's she's supportive but i think
that she's just so confident in my
ability to
stay true to who i am in this industry
was your dad in your life he's not
never was
briefly my dad was also um
fell victim to alcoholism and drug abuse
and he just wasn't he was very absent in
my life do you think that plays a factor
in
the fact that you're doing this i've
thought about that too
and so it's not like the stigmatism of
like daddy issues that really put me in
this industry it was the sole focus on
like i'm gonna be rich i'm gonna be rich
i'm gonna be rich
but
i think that the combination of not
having my dad and then having my mom on
drugs
definitely like
stemmed all the anxiety that i had in my
life growing up and to this day and kind
of pushed me to do something that's out
of the norm
yeah what you're doing is very out of
the norm it's different for sure
definitely getting more popular though
see more and more girls coming in
really for sure
i watched some of them crumble
like they just can't handle it i don't
blame them
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your time doing
this
that's a great question that i have
never thought about before
the most important thing i have learned
being a dancer
is
i think that it's just given me
more perspective
on life and people
um like now i'm able to empathize with
the other girls that are there doing
what they do versus before i ever even
considered this i was like no they're
they're all [ __ ] like i could never do
that i could never be touched
and now i've just got a little bit
better perspective
i can kind of
level with people and try to figure out
where they're coming from
in all situations of my life because
this isn't necessarily something that i
would want to do
and that like i said i feel like i have
to fight people to tell them that like
no i'm not falling susceptible to all
the things that you think
so definitely
just being a little bit more open-minded
excellent
yeah all right alexis thank you so much
for sharing your story and i wish you
the best of luck after school thanks so
much thank you very much
you